we're releasing 20,000 male mosquitoes
and the hopes to reduce the population
by making their eggs not viable
these mosquitoes have will ba kiya and
when these male mosquitoes with lavake
mate with the wild mosquitoes that are
found in this area the result is
infertile egg production so the females
will lay eggs that are not fertile will
not hatch and will not produce other
generations every Wednesday and Friday
members of the Clovis mosquito abatement
team pick up a box from the post office
shipped to them from a lab in Kentucky
inside that box are twenty tubes each
containing one thousand male mosquitoes
infected with a bacterium that will
render the eggs of any female they mate
with infertile project manager Steve
Mulligan says it took a little
explaining to persuade residents of this
neighborhood in Clovis California to
allow them to dump 40,000 mosquitoes in
their front yards every week we left
door hangers on the homes in the
neighborhood we had an evening where
they could come to the park to discuss
what we were doing but it is unusual I
mean the idea of releasing mosquitoes to
control mosquitoes that's kind of
thinking outside outside of the box but
in the age of Zika virus which is spread
from South America to parts of Florida
and even Central California people are
open to new ideas to eliminate a species
of mosquito that's responsible for
millions of human deaths around the
world historically this was the the
primary vector the mosquito that
transmitted yellow fever the mosquito is
also the primary vector for dengue these
are devastating diseases which can cause
fatality and more troubling is the fact
that this mosquito is the primary vector
for this new emerging disease zika virus
but while the residents of Clovis have
been open to the audacious experiment of
releasing bacteria late and insects into
their neighborhoods
there are other proposals that have
proven far more controversial scientists
hoping to use a new weapon genetically
modified mosquitoes insects with
modified DNA have never come this close
to being set loose in a residential
neighborhood a company called Oxitec
engineered a mosquito in a lab to
produce similar infertility effects but
because this method involved
genetic modification as opposed to
bacterial infection Florida Keys
residents formed a resistance movement
to the GM mosquito we don't want to be
guinea pigs why would we take a risk of
allowing a GMO product into our most
fragile environment but with lives on
the line scientists like Zachary Adelman
in Texas AM question the morality of
opposition to genetically modified
mosquitoes as we're considering the
risks and this notion of precautionary
that that until we understand this
technology inside it out and have
studied it for a hundred years
we should never apply it to the field
well while you're waiting and while
you're being precautionary tens of
thousands of people children are going
to die of hemorrhagic fever from things
like dengue where children will be born
hundreds or thousands of children will
be born with microcephaly because of
Zika or or in Africa hundreds of
thousands of children will die per year
from malaria
Adelman and his team have modified the
genomes of mosquitoes with the
cutting-edge gene editing technology
CRISPR when the transgenic mosquitoes
mate with non modified mosquitoes the
offspring will be male and so far his
method has been working so now we're
designing new transgenic streams we can
link it with this so-called gene Drive
where a gene would be able to be
inherited beyond 50% of these super
rates where almost all approach me would
carry this team and if all the progeny
were carrying this gene for male nest
and you would have imagined that all the
progeny would be males and that would
happen each generation eventually you'd
run into a problem or we wouldn't the
mosquitoes would run into a problem they
would run out of females and then there
would be no more eggs and then
that for them one common objection that
Adelman encounters is that wiping out a
species of mosquito could have
unintended consequences on our ecosystem
if you rewind the clock 400 years this
mosquito doesn't exist here and so it is
in an invasive it's a new mosquito so
there are no species that are dependent
on it that must eat it to survive those
there's no evidence that any species
like that exists for any mosquito but of
course you don't see the same kind of
protests with people talking about
pesticides the results from the releases
in Clovis the Florida Keys and South and
Central America are yet to be seen
Adelman plans to push his project
forward as quickly as the science and
the public and regulators will allow him
you're always gonna have a vocal
percentage of the population the
question is does that vocal percentage
that shows up to the town hall meetings
and is in the street and is very active
in social media do they truly represent
the entire community or do they not
represent the entire community but where
these trials have gone on in places like
Brazil and Panama where you have a much
stronger disease burden where everybody
they know somebody who's had dengue or
there they've had children who have had
dengue they understand the severity of
the disease very very passionately and
very personally you haven't seen that in
strong resistance and I think that that
plays are all certainly in people's
minds
[Music]
you